alrighty this is the moment Evan this is
the moment we're going away we're going
away where are we going we're going to
Alaska for how long for I don't know how
long two weeks ten days 12 days 10 14
days I think so something like that yeah
we're taking them with us yeah taking
them with us yeah yeah great yeah it's
all right it's not our honeymoon I keep
saying honeymoon
every day is a honeymoon
uh I slept three hours last night so I'm
a little
uh it's early Sun is just Rising we're
heading to the airport going to Alaska
and we'll see how many videos this ends
up taking and Nina's gonna be doing most
of the talking and narrating
that's that's that's what I do you know
it's gonna it's gonna be just anyway
okay our car's here let's go to the
airport
we're arrived
arrive of course yeah it's very busy it
is yeah we just have to like not to scan
our um
okay yeah you're ready yeah I'm ready
let's go it was a very busy line chaos I
can stop twice yeah randomly check why
are you telling me when you no you're
doing a bad stuff because to show you
because you like your one you're happy
when I got stopped I was happy with you
guys yeah because you always laughed at
me well that's true she got randomly
checked and then she got stopped for
having too many liquids but not too many
just my bag it just seems fake anyway
we're here Cheers Cheers
[Music]
wearing the silver shirts
half silver is supposed to help against
radiation we'll see and and stay excited
to be going got my sleep mask ready I
had three hours sleep last night so
let's see if this works tonight
[Music]
we just landed in Vancouver now we're
rushing to our gate to Anchorage unless
Alaska yeah yeah it's kind of rushed
they kind of slow they it was delay a
little bit everything's happened to us
yeah it's okay we're making it
[Music]
yeah so we rushed to Pasta to get
through the the Border because Evan
thought that we only have very limited
time but we actually have like almost
two hours two hours yeah that's fine
that's good I'm just ready
well that huge is glowing
you're glowing you're really I look tiny
and you're like giants yeah I'm Giant
so we got into the lounge okay we're
gonna do some work event yeah and then
what else you're gonna do I'm going to
write a poem for Nina what's the phone
about
um
Nina is cute
he doesn't play the
it looks after things
okay anyways we're gonna chill for a
couple hours before we go to our gate
and then go up to Anchorage
we're ready to hop on our second flight
what did you do Evan oh I got some
killer work done I'll tell you about it
okay so good I'm excited to hear about
it yeah sometimes when you go away you
know it just inspiration hits this is
really good why do I look weird oh I'm
pushing two bags somebody can hold the
camera yeah let's go to film you to film
me right why am I on camera you're the
star of the show no you're the star
[Music]
wow
foreign
[Music]
stopped Evan while we're looking for the
the pickup ride the Rideshare whatever
yeah CJ yeah he's a photographer from uh
Florida
California no I think he's in Florida
yeah okay stop me so we did a we did a
quick little IG star give him some love
why not give us some motivation for
believe Nation okay
um what you do in the present moment
will directly affect your future so make
sure you stay in the present moment if
you have something that you want to
manifest or create you want to just
focus on the present moment and step by
step just take it as it comes don't be
too much in the future because it's hard
to get everything all done in one day so
Rome wasn't built in a day let's go
that's CJ go check him out
while we arrive at the hotel but we have
some um
I don't know whatever say take me
anyways anyway we got everything figured
out and then we're gonna head to our
room
foreign
we started our day at 5 30 this morning
and then it is 9 00 p.m Toronto time I
think but it is what time is it in
Anchorage time four five no buy
something
I don't know we'll get there fast and
then we'll take it slow
way down in Kokomo
it's a Caribbean place but Anchorage you
know we'll get there fast and then we'll
take it slow although we're gonna take
it slow tomorrow I don't know maybe
we'll see
the mountains okay that looks pretty
cool
it looks pretty good
there's a couch
and then bed mini fridge bathroom oh
Evan is hangry am I angry yeah we're
gonna go to humpy's Great Alaskan
something
and we're gonna have
their famous smoked salmon chowder I
don't like smoked salmon whatever
two oysters for Nina and their Famous
Fish and Chips
and some local beer
that's good
[Music]
we have arrived at the hampi's
restaurant apparently they have really
nice food by this area
they haven't picked it it's a legend
legendary place here we're gonna get
fish and chips fish and chips oysters
for you smoked salmon chowder chowder
and some local beer that they're famous
for we'll see
[Music]
wow very fruity for an IPA
okay Nina's having her first Alaskan
meal smoked salmon chowder I don't like
smoked salmon but Nina does and it's and
it's soup I like Smooth salmon on the
bagel and then put cream cheese on it
and then put some paper on this oh
sounds so gross uh yuck I hate silk
salmon and it smells very smoked salmon
which is good for her I'll probably have
a bite and see if I like it but how was
it good
to have something warm hey hey
it is raining outside okay nice okay try
the this is the king
Alaskan crab nuggets thank you
Alaskan king crab nuggets There She Goes
she's putting some lemon on it
and she's gonna try one
it's happening with with their
the sauce I guess
and there it goes
just okay
too much bread okay but the soup was a
winner perfect Okay evan this is the
famous fish and chips that you ordered
fish and chips Alaskan halibut fish and
chips
with their special tartar sauce
oh wow
wow
that sounds really good very juicy oh
juicy yum
you are surprising
okay good oh my God
how is the food Evan oh the food
definitely looks good yeah I got mugged
on the way out though what do you mean
you got mine lost my hoodie oh yeah
because because I'm cold so I need to I
need to worry I got mugged yeah that's
okay that's fine yeah
I'm actually kind of tired I think
because it's been a long day it's 10
o'clock for us 10 30 for us so we've
been out for how many hours uh what time
do we get up 5 30.
I mean I was up at 3 30. okay yeah it's
been I don't know it's a lot of hours
yeah
back to the hotel
shower wanting down sleep I have an
amazing day with this woman tomorrow
good morning Evan
good morning everybody day one day one
yeah Day Zero perfect day one yesterday
was a long day Zero yeah day one Nina
slept like crazy it was great so happy
for you yeah okay now we're going to
breakfast
[Music]
next stop is the Indian Valley mine
what's so good about this Evan just to
stop along the way
Indian gift shop I don't know we'll see
what's in here
[Music]
there's somebody from everybody look at
that
I found my somebody
[Music]
do you enjoy this oh it's fine yeah yeah
Okay now what's next then we're gonna
take uh not a zip line a uh what's it
called uh I kind of feel like the cable
car cable car to the top of something
and have beautiful views apparently
let's go
we arrived we're going up there
what's there
[Music]
Evan yo I have a sad news why it's not
working oh no yeah they haven't worked
since this morning oh wow yeah they're
trying to fix it but they don't know but
we can call later to see if they open
okay yeah
okay I think there's a well we could
walk it but that's probably a big walk
yeah
okay well let's continue on yeah
and then uh we're gonna go to the we'll
go to the um Wildlife Sanctuary so this
is where they take a bunch of uh
they adopt a bunch of animals like
they're wounded animals or orphan
animals uh and they put them in a
sanctuary and you can get up close
person with them Nina likes animals so I
thought you'd like that so we'll go
there what's that I don't know it
depends on what kind of animal okay well
we'll see hope you like one of them at
least
uh we'll go there and then we'll call
and see if we can come back here
what are you laughing I was laughing
because I remember this morning what
when I said you had to try the pineapple
because Alaska is known for its
pineapple he's like oh my God really
[Laughter]
I love pineapple
that's how much I trusted you yeah
sometimes I play some pranks but it's
we had a good time you enjoyed the laugh
right
foreign
[Music]
like the wild animal center
uh it was good yeah it was good got to
see some animals super close yeah
they're all orphaned or injured or
rescue animals so it's cool they have
this place for them to to uh be happy
Nina Nina liked it she got cold at the
end yeah my ears got really cold so
we're almost uh yeah we saw basically
everything yeah now we're gonna get back
it's starting to get cold outside now
overcast my brain so maybe we'll call
you want to call the um tram place we'll
call the tram place there's no there's
no signal here so we can't really call
yet but call the tram place if we can go
there and uh there was still that bird
stop along the way as we make our way
slowly back to Anchorage
[Music]
so we arrived at this bird point
but it's so windy yeah
check it out
[Music]
next up is The Pita Place Nina found it
yeah it's not a like pizza not a typical
travel place that we will always go to
apparently they have lots of unique
pizzas and flavors I'm just going to
look up our reviews or their reviews and
see what they got
but uh the carnivore Pizza
that sounds good already
yeah it smells really good
we order beer and root beer float yeah
this is their their most famous drinks
this is their apple ale I'll give it a
try
[Music]
oh wow it's good I wouldn't guess apples
very like Fruity at the end but I
wouldn't guess halfway that's pretty
good and this is their famous homemade
root beer with local vanilla a little
bit of vanilla ice cream on top I
haven't had root beer in forever
oh yeah oh very light it's good all
right so far so good so we ordered their
most famous pizzas which are apricot and
reindeer so we'll see how those go but
Nina was really hungry so we're gonna we
got their famous uh actually this is not
famous this is smoked salmon something
just so that you can eat something right
away while we wait half an hour for our
pizzas and good you happy all right how
smoked salmon is it no okay okay good
good good let's go okay so this is it
this is a giant pizza this is apricot
sauce and stuff and this is all of the
wild with reindeer so sausage on here
okay so which one you're gonna try first
let's go
apricot actually I'm gonna go let's go
this one first reindeer
these are giant pizza
okay let's get that
reindeer pizza first
it's a cream sauce it's good very
different that was a good find Evan yeah
the pizza is good yeah yeah I found that
it must be amazing yeah let me know like
Brainiac yeah genius yeah yeah you found
it yeah yeah yeah
uh going back home yeah no we're not
going back home we're going back to the
hotel because home will be in Toronto
so we're already home Evan are you
excited
today we're going to the cruise we're
gonna have a big headache but yes oh
sorry okay if you didn't sleep well it's
okay we're uh yeah today's today is
Tuesday yeah let's see if we got
upgraded to the train or we're taking
the bus yeah we're gonna have our last
breakfast at the hotel and then head on
to the boat
foreign
we have an hour before we get on to the
boat to the cruise so we're gonna get a
coffee you have a special place Evan
uh yeah yeah yeah hope you like it okay
thank you best oh lattes okay
and they have clients
[Music]
this is the coffee shop not K Street
Market
it's the that feeling cold plant and
coffee
[Music]
try it
do you like it yeah wow really good
better dance today this might be the
best trailer they've ever had it's good
why did you want to come to Alaska
because
it's a place I've never been with you
okay yeah and I want to go with you
huh foreign
place and then but we decided to come
back for in this market they have this
famous bread so we're gonna come back to
get them scones and the croissant is
good too yeah
[Music]
so yeah we went back initially we were
we were thinking just to get the
croissant uh and then the the scone but
then I ended I got a sandwich and a soup
because I love soup
and we're gonna talk about the guy
behind us oh yeah yeah what about it oh
yeah he was like so I was filming with
Evan just to tell I forgot what we were
talking about and the guys I tried to
make it in it was so funny it's like
yeah he's like doing this and then even
when Evan was doing the story he's like
trying to get in or when we took a
picture he tried to get in that was
funny and right now we're gonna go back
to the hotel pick up our stuff and then
um hop on our bus
let's go
[Music]
foreign
a king-size bed so they gave us twin
size instead
who could ask them to put it together
but it's a nice room
looking
outside
[Music]
you like it yeah
we're fishing on vacation
good
so what I really like about this boat
the first impression is the orchids
every floor every lounge every room they
have an orchids over there yeah they
have like real orchids it's not just
like fake orchids that you see that does
on it but these are really real do they
smell no okay it doesn't smell but
they're so real they're so no they're
real like they're real I was telling
Evans like oh before we like when we
talk can I just ask them for a orchid to
take home he said no
sadness
[Music]
there's Nina's dessert
like the heart
this bonus thing here
fruit and honey
just like a bear like Winnie the Pooh
it's in there
good so we just finished our dinner
dinner is actually really good it's
worth it Evan said that that restaurant
is really hard to book but we got lucky
we went in there at six o'clock and they
let us in
and funny thing is like you have to
dress very formal yeah I was using my
t-shirt and Evan in his sweater hello
what's more formal than this
yeah I know it stayed they actually put
a suit jacket on Evan's chair just to
show that it's a formal night
on the chair yeah yeah so food's good uh
next up what are you gonna what are we
gonna do Evan deciding deciding what to
do looking at the agenda okay okay
okay so let's talk about last night Evan
last night last night we walked around
last night okay okay we walk we walk
around the boat a little bit and then we
came back
okay we came out working it I just fell
asleep okay I passed out Nina passed out
on this couch yeah on this couch yeah I
took a picture with her I've been I've
been taking pictures with Nina as she's
asleep I go she's here
so I have like four of those pictures
now I'm gonna remember yeah I'm gonna
see if I can get 10 on this trip
ten oh my God
oh well it's a brand new day and we're
gonna see the glaciers today which is
exciting but if you want to see the
glaciers the radio is going to be right
here so you can go watch that we'll see
you there police